hello
welcome back to big mood welcome
i am tiff who else is here i am nikki
there we go
i am gina stop being [ __ ] copycats
like every time
me jess i'm i'm running on a little bit
of a migraine so i'm a little [ __ ]
right now we match with the ocean tide
okay
all right so uh today we're gonna be
discussing some stories that sex workers
have shared
about the most randomest like wildest
things that they've done
on the job and i found this article here
that kind of lists them out but this
question was posed
in reddit so this is where these answers
are coming from
from reddit it says sex workers what's
the weirdest thing
someone wanted to pay you to do that you
actually did
yeah i mean they must get some of the
weirdest [ __ ] ever i'm so intrigued by
this because i feel like
i don't know is it is it normal that
like all of us have thought about it at
one point
like that yeah i did yeah yeah yeah
yeah like didn't you answer the rumors i
am a sex worker oh yeah yeah yeah
we currently have a sex worker on set
gina probably wrote all of these
right this is gina's list you guys i'm
like the poorest sex worker ever
probably
you're like the dumbest one is better
you're not making a good profit
that's funny oh yeah that's true i did
have that thought
crossed my mind at one point i did
consider cam girling at one point
i feel like the people who messaged me
for like hey can i see your titties or
your feet whatever they never
offer money like are all my do i only
attract oh core fans
yeah you do because i have people
messaging me like
i just want to spoil you just yeah take
my credit card number whatever you want
no questions asked and i'm like i don't
i feel uncomfortable
i do get those but they're always from
like fake accounts yeah yeah i don't
think they're real that's why i'm like
i'm not an
idiot with your fake ass offer okay
yeah because that's the same thing just
trying to see if you'll send them nudes
if you
if they say they'll send you money they
request them i send you money they
request like if i'm in a picture with
socks on they like want to buy my socks
off me like the dirty socks
or something like that i have a lot of
feet people
put your cash up in your profile and if
they send you a thousand dollars then
you'll mail it to them yeah
none of this fake ass yeah i've never
even engaged i don't have a cash app
either so
yeah yeah some some russian girl with
like a bunch of photos and followers
messaged me and
all it said was you send me money
so instead of people sending me money
now i have people asking me for money
that's how you're so poor so you gave
her money
goddamn you're the worst sex worker yeah
that's hilarious all right so first
story here it says
i had a guy who's fetish was getting
scammed so he paid me
come on yeah every time one of those
like scammers call like your amazon has
been hacked he's like
i don't know anymore i'm half heart
yeah so they wrote so he paid me 70
for a 25 pair of panties and then had me
send him a video of telling him how dumb
he was for falling for my scam
oh he likes humiliation yeah and then
it must be like responsible at work or
something that's true
because it's usually like someone who's
in control at work or like a
high-powered
position where like they tell everyone
what to do they want to get oh
they want to be ashamed basically yeah
and then they continued another guy
liked video chatting with me and just
having my camera face
just having my camera face my wall while
i did work and i'd ignore him while he
said while he sent me messages about how
sexy i was
but it's the easiest come through
you know i want all those ones that are
like what are they called um
something pig pay pig pay pigs yeah what
is that
you're just like give me a hundred
dollars you don't like and there's no
questions
okay like it gets them hard to just give
you a hundred dollars
it's like there's not enough of those
how do we find these people
i've seen videos on like to talk on
twitter where like the woman would
open the door and he's just on his knees
just money like you just take my money
she's like you filthy animal just slams
the door on him my friend had a slave
for a while
oh like where he they want to be slaves
right so they have like they have a
collar for them
and this is not kink shaming at all i
just thought it was really fascinating
because like she just
actually shamed it casually had a slave
and he would
he was not allowed like he would make
her not let him
walk on two legs like so he had to crawl
everywhere
um he also like had to do whatever she
said even if it was like you're not
allowed to contact me that was
his punishment was like take your caller
off like was his punishment for doing
something bad
and he would like just do her laundry
naked like have to do like
a bunch of her chores like basically she
had like a a maid
yeah and made that paid her yeah
to to be the man and beg to like
clean and stuff do you fulfill her
wishes yeah
all right what the heck yeah we're in
the wrong business y'all
why are we doing a podcast it kind of
reminds me of that one chick from
euphoria
euphoria oh yeah yeah she just became
like a dumb
like a dumb but like video cam dom so
she would just have people like talk
[ __ ] to people and then they'd have to
like send her money
yeah like a cat that's interesting yeah
i think her name is
so interesting it's fascinating i don't
think i don't think though in reality i
could do it because i just can't be
around
degenerate men i'm like so disgusted by
men on
like a normal level that if i have to
deal with like the shitty ones like that
i'm like i am a kink shamer
i don't know if it's shitty though
shitty thing yeah like very some of them
might be like really powerful there's
something wrong with them i mean
obviously there's something wrong with
me
not down i want it i mean everyone has
something wrong with them i think
this is just the way they cope yeah but
i'm still not down i really wanted both
of them to come on the podcast but
um he's not her slave anymore and also
he has to be anonymous because he has
like
an actual high-powered job wow yeah
so interesting how would we have an
anonymous guest here i know right with
the mask and a voice changer like he has
to because he
has the collar on that'd be fun that'd
be cool all right next one
my friend is an escort she had a regular
who would want
her to sit in a robe and slippers while
chain smoking cigarettes oddly he didn't
ever want to have sex with her he just
wanted her sitting in his company that
way
that's like mommy issues this is the
easiest way that's a really weird
would you start a nicotine addiction for
thousands of dollars
i don't know how to really hardly get it
off you have to already know smoker yeah
how much do you how much would you guys
charge for this
huh yeah since i don't smoke like that
would be pretty hard for me
mm-hmm i used to smoke i'm a former
smoker but i've quit tonight to wear now
so it might be hard to smoking kind of
grosses me out so i'm like
well back when you were a smoker when i
was a smoker [ __ ]
just buy my cigarettes oh my gosh wow
it's a strong addiction they have those
fake uh vape cigarettes for nicky that
they
are inhaling lavender oh yeah i have i
actually tried one of those
oh yeah yeah i had the monk or something
yeah monk but then
i was reading that like it's not healthy
to inhale essential oils either so i was
like oh okay
well i just won't do anything you should
be inhaling anything but air
yeah that's true oh yeah so how much
um five thousand dollars per second for
one
time i just like don't care yeah you'd
probably be puking because you're
exactly yeah not to
sweet dream cigarettes i did those a
couple times they're like vanilla or
chocolate flavored
whatever i think they're like they're
probably getting banned because yeah
it gets kids addicted to cigarettes i'm
sure so it has tobacco in it
yeah it's it's like it's a real
cigarette but it just tastes like
vanilla or that is dangerous we didn't
have vapes when i was growing up so that
was like the closest thing to like a
flavored
something that enclosed what about
eugena a former smoker gina probably
like a thousand like that chick but now
like quitting smoking gina
a lot like jess said cause you if like
by the time you quit smoking as a smoker
i smoked for like 14 years or something
like
no it's not yeah it's not really worth
any amount of money the amount to get
off of it yeah is so hard that's true
yeah
i mean i i'm not a smoker at all i mean
like
i saw you take a cigarette
exactly girl so i'm not a smoker so
chain's smoking cigarettes i would for
sure [ __ ] vomit
so for me it would have to be a high
rate in a short amount of time
yeah a short amount of time in high rate
i think it was a smoker in a past life
though because whenever i get stressed
out i imagine myself smoking cigarettes
but if i when
yeah but it's not stressful it forces
you to take deep breaths
because i used to smoke hookah yeah and
that was really relaxing because
it forced me to take deep breaths which
i don't normally do i think i have
normal shallow breaths
and i pretty much get stressed out
easily yeah i thought you were gonna say
that
past life you were smoker because
whenever you get stressed out you start
talking like this
this is how you talk to people do they
still do those things oh yeah
i was addicted yes
dang all right next one someone i will
never forget
is the blood blood fetish guy oh
he made a small cut on his arm and let
the blood drip
onto his penis then gave himself a hand
job with it i just had to watch and say
dirty stuff to him
it's pretty hot i thought he was going
to eat it or sorry to eat it like army
hammer or something like that yeah same
love gets sticky and that doesn't feel
good to like it just dries
yeah i imagine he's like jacking off and
it like
maybe one thrust it's wet and then it's
just dry all of a sudden and then it's
tacky right or what if he's constantly
wetting it with
him jerking off because
because like have you ever had sex on
your period and get somewhere and like
after all it's sticking your body kind
of sticks together
because your blood it doesn't sound fun
at all no i used to be the
like i remember like i was the girl me
and my ex used to have like
it was the most angelini jelly [ __ ]
the vile of blood of each other's blood
no that's so that's actually about
angelina jolie that's a [ __ ] megan
fox and
she and kelly they do that oh
she kissed her brother or something on
the lips or something like that yeah
anyway interesting so how did you guys
even do that like
where'd you get yeah we're miles or what
blood
uh like you cut your finger and then
like there's the vials and then
you sat there and [ __ ] drip yeah
dripped into it like what we had to do
for our fertility time
yeah yeah but now i didn't even like now
after you guys told me about the
fertility test i don't even want to do
that what the heck
yeah it did it's just a little prick i
mean mine was produced for two weeks see
yeah yeah she's not helping us on my
finger i've never didn't know thank you
guys
like that for like three days it just
depends on how fast you yeah she's not
helping
but yeah in the vial that you can buy
they have like this chemical inside of
it that
preserves the blood from rotting and
then you just wear it on your own oh so
it stays does it like stay red
mm-hmm interesting it doesn't coagulate
yeah i can't even handle when like i
smash a mosquito and my own blood
like splatters out well i'm just
thinking that it's not my blood i'm like
i just got hiv from someone else's blood
i feel like mosquitoes are carrying hiv
and it's all over me
yeah what if it's not my blood yeah ew
because if it just lands
and you if you just see it and you smash
it the blood is probably someone else's
ew
jesse you ruined it like a dog or like a
cow or
something [ __ ] she lives near cows
oh my god i can totally make money like
if there's a kink out there that wants
my blood i get nosebleeds
every summer i can fill up jugs if you
guys want to buy my blood
i have so many memories of gina with
tissue stuffed up her nose
and i don't even see her that often
that's true it looks like bart bart's
nose is always
oh yeah is that an asian thing to have
common nosebleeds no
not in my family i think so cause casey
never gets them no
i don't think so but that wouldn't like
weird you out though like
having someone have like your dna like
that i don't know
what i mean what are they gonna do with
it they're not gonna like what like
they're gonna have like a dna
conspiracy tips showed up yeah yeah
what's up with the having your dna thing
i mean not a crime scene
obviously i don't care about it that
much because i did the dna test
yeah so there's my dna's in some
freaking lab somewhere
but i don't know like if someone's
buying it off of me
that would make me feel weird they can't
do what are you trying to try
how do you know i mean if they're going
to clone me and make another one of me
that's their problem now
they're going to murder someone and put
your blood on their crime scene no
that's true but then i can always be
like no dude you gotta have the receipts
they bought that blood from me
yeah i don't know i think about that too
with like selling used
underwear or socks i'm like my skin
cells are on there
it's just oh i never thought about that
it's just
like degrades or something i don't know
i just don't see that being a
yeah i mean you can't even sneeze on a
crime scene and then they freak out
truly i don't know if my blood were to
put be put in a crime scene they would
test it and find like
cheetos blood and blood or like like
mucus or like snot in there and i just
tell the cops like dude it came from my
nose i'm selling it they're like
there's boogers in there oh yeah see my
business you want do you want to buy a
vial yeah
they don't want to just buy vials of
blood they want you to be there like
bleeding on them
they can just dump it on themselves and
jack off there we go
you're not going to start a line if
you're a blood gina's nose bloodline
yeah
that girl sold her bath water yeah if
you're a blood freak let us know
if you would actually buy vials of it or
if you want it live
true i feel like they want it live and
also how much would you charge
for your dna [ __ ] imagine this much a
thousand dollars like a thousand bucks
for this much dude i can fulfill that in
like [ __ ]
they could just go to a [ __ ] blood
bankruptcy
if they want it from the person yeah
it's me you guys want some degenerate
blood no they'll definitely analyze it
too because remember that bathwater
chick they actually
analyzed the water to see if there was
any human skin cells in it and they were
like see
she lied there's no human skin zelda why
don't you even fake that because it's
the easiest thing just [ __ ] in your
bath and you know
why would you but why because she
probably thinks it could make it
where it's like why do you want your dna
out there with people
no integrity orange's new black where
they were selling prison panties but
then
the person they were the go-to guy
figured out how to create the scent
so then he was creating it on his own if
you could not sit in a bathtub
and sell fake water that's way easier
true alright next one my girlfriend used
to work as a phone sex operator
the other workers for the line used a
message board where they would
where they would talk about clients and
maybe recommend them to one another
she said the weirdest call she got was
from a guy whose fantasy was to be a
chicken
however she was supposed to trick him
into cooking him
she said she said the phone calls would
usually go on about if he was a dirty
chicken and would need a bath
but then she would turn the heat up and
casually add ingredients under false
pretenses
i just want to know where in life you're
a dirty chicken you need a bath get in
here right
it's nice and warm like he wants to be
boiled like a frog so where he doesn't
know
i guess like yeah spoiled to death she's
like slowly chopping carrots
like that yeah [ __ ] chicken where the
[ __ ] does that stem
right i want to know what at what point
in your life that that
something went crazy and turned you on
and turned you on about being
like there was sex right after you saw a
chicken being boiled or something like
right because then
i forgot where i read this or heard this
but there was i remember hearing about a
story where there was this guy
who was into god damn i really can't
remember
which i'm ruining the whole [ __ ]
story but the point is it was a really
odd fetish
and the way that he became like this
became a fetish for him was because
we're the very first time that he
experienced this odd thing which i don't
even want to make it up because i forgot
what it was
um right after that happened that's when
he had his first sexual experience so he
linked it
so interesting that's what i'm thinking
like so like this guy lost his virginity
after he
had sunday dinner when his mom cooked a
chicken or something
the parents were arguing he like lost
virginia in the back
barn yeah before i knew what sex was
where you just have feelings like when
you're a kid when you're
developing and you just you don't know
why what these feelings are or where to
put them
i would have like weird fetishes i think
i talked about one before with the final
goes west yeah yeah
uh where he got rolled up in a burrito
oh right burrito girl yeah
yeah and then i would roll myself up in
things because i
just wanted that like feeling of not
being in control and
i remember that scene and it would turn
it would turn me on but i didn't know
that's what it was because i was a kid
so i didn't know just like eight years
old rolling yourself yeah i just had
this fetish of like being rolled up or
if i was in the pool
i would like um i would hold my bathing
suit straps because of one piece
and like i would like hold myself up
against the wall like as if someone was
holding me up against the wall and i
couldn't go anywhere
and when i see like people get duct
taped to walls like i
really just wanted to be like completely
like not able to use my arms
and then there was also this book that
my mom used to read um
it was like this this book about bunny
like the main character was a bunny
right
and he wasn't meant to tell me about
this
george it was a child's book
but he was like a regular bunny and then
his older sister bunnies
um dressed him up like a baby and made
him drink a baby bottle and we're like
you're a little baby he's like no i'm
not
and that turned me on and i would like i
was at a babysitter's house with a bunch
of other kids and i would always want to
be the baby and like make them
like treat me like a baby and make me
drink a bottle even though i'm like
way older than that yeah so i had like i
can get
the line of thinking right for these
weird fetishes but it was before
i actually like had sex and like right
was it adults having sex
because you didn't you had no idea what
you were like i didn't know
why i was feeling that way from reading
those books or from
they have a blanket that looks like a
tortilla and i'm just gonna send it to
you
i have that blanket yeah
wrap yourself up have fun just go nuts
i'm like in ends i'm okay steve
right hey baby you're gonna text me piss
you know what the [ __ ]
or you're like roll me up baby roll me
up right tell me i'm a burrito
i'm your chalupa so when you're a kid
did fruit roll-ups turn you on
no oh my god she's wrapping her gummy
worms
gummy bears in a fruit roll that's a
different food
it's not her body yeah and he's not my
preference
it's so funny but yeah like i totally
get what you're saying too because like
i remember climbing in the jungle gym
and
feeling like trying like climbing up the
pole and like
rubbing oh yeah up against the pole not
knowing why but it felt good and i would
just
do it but i'm like but i didn't even
realize there was something sexual
yeah like way later that i was like oh
[ __ ] this sexual feeling is the same
feeling i got from that pole when i was
in [ __ ] kindergarten
exactly you'll connect the dots to like
way later yeah oh yeah there was another
one where i watched cartoons
where the dog would get the dog got
kicked like the dog was trying to like
sneak in to it was like one of those
bugs bunny cartoons and the dog kept
trying to sneak in
and he like got kicked in the butt out
and i would make
like i would have people like kick me in
the butt
okay wow you're really turned beyond
the strangest person jesus christ well
if you're ever
if you ever want a burrito
[Laughter]
delivered to you because it's orange you
need a cerrito right from taco bell
and it turns you on for some reason you
have doordash yay
doordash is chipotle food delivery app
and it connects you with the restaurants
you love right now and right to your
door
and now you can get the grocery
essentials you need to with doordash
get drinks snacks tortillas and
other household items delivered in under
an hour
ordering is easy open the doordash app
choose what you want
from where you want and your items will
be left safely outside your door with
the contact list delivery drop-off
setting you don't have to talk to them
with over 300 000 partners in the us
puerto rico
canada and australia you can support
your neighborhood go-to's or choose from
your favorite national restaurants like
popeye's chipotle and the cheesecake
factory
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on your
first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code
mood that's 25 off up to a 10
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter the code
mood don't forget once again that's mood
code mood for 25 off your first order
with doordash
subject change terms apply and while
you're eating that food you want to be
munching down with some straight teeth
right
yeah yeah that's where our next sponsor
comes wrap your teeth in some clear
liners
some clear aligners so shout outs to
candid
so thousands of people have used candid
the clear comfortable removable and
practically invisible aligners that help
straighten your teeth
and now they love their smile because
they're not
having that metal brace face having to
deal with all those wires
you can't remove them when you eat you
get food stuck in them every you have to
actually go into the office
every time you want to get them adjusted
or to continue your treatment you
constantly have to drive out there
wait in line or whatever you have to
wait for your appointment sit in the
chair
go through that painful experience it's
not fun
but with candid you can avoid all of
that because your treatment
um can be done straight from your home
like you never have to leave your house
your treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement
you'll have the same quality of care
you'd get from an in-office orthodontist
from the comfort and convenience of your
own home
and while other companies use general
dentists candid only works with
orthodontists
so you never have to wonder and by the
way you from
the very beginning of your treatment
plan to the end you're always with the
same orthodontist
so you'll never have to wonder how
you're doing the average candid
treatment is just six months you'll
start seeing results way before then and
it costs
thousands of dollars less than
traditional braces
so become your best you start
straightening your teeth today
right now you can save 75 dollars on
candids starter kit go to
candidco.com mood and use code
mood that's candid co.com
mood code mood take advantage of this
limited time offer to save
75 on your starter kit candid co.com
mood code mood straight teeth straight
teeth
yeah all right so let's see what's up
next in this
very fun lipstick it's super these are
better than i was expecting yeah
a chicken went through me for a while
right i don't know where it was going
all right here's the next one it says i
used to sell my used socks for a pretty
penny see
yeah a lot of people do it they wanted
nasty
disgusting worn these same socks for two
weeks while doing outdoor activities in
the burning hot sun type of socks
i always included a list of the things i
did while wearing the socks like
mowed the grass went out for a run for
four days in a week
played roller derby walked on the beach
went to zumba classes etc
dude so yeah that guy that offered to
buy my socks off me
um he said if i wasn't willing to sell
them to him if i could just describe how
they smell
or describe like what i was doing in
them
yeah i no i i didn't ask him
and i actually he doesn't even know i
saw it until unless he listens to this
oh well now he knows my only concern
about this is i know she's probably just
like
putting the socks on doing some activity
getting kind of sweaty taking them off
and
probably showering or something but even
still just having like your foot
exposed to like something that dirty
over and over and over for two weeks
like
she's gonna get a toenail fungus or
something oh my god i was thinking the
exact same thing when i read that one
because i was just like wouldn't you
have some sort of like
hygiene healthy like health
repercussions out of
doing this because i all that bacteria
growth and like your shoes must be
[ __ ] crazy so i'm like yeah what's
going on
that bad it has to be full of [ __ ]
bacteria he'll probably pay extra for
the fungus
oh i never thought of that then you got
to go through a whole
treatment you got to take these
anti-fungal pills to get your toes back
in order
anyway moving on i would just take my
husband's socks
because they i keep one day but they're
too big
i shower so i know wear my socks for a
day honey
he's she said that i'm on like this much
of his foot because he sweats so much
like because he's so hygienic sometimes
he takes two showers a day but
he sweats a lot so his socks are
everywhere and
oh dude i just imagine you're sending
you send steve sucks i wore these
it's huge stompers yeah
that was a pretty good guess though yeah
it was all right next one my boyfriend
used to be a sex worker and he once got
a woman who said she'd pay him to just
lay his head across her lap and let her
play with his hair for a few hours it
sounds like gina was that gina
he did so you do and after yeah i mean i
love doing i'm not gonna pay for it
yeah i have plenty of people who would
want to do it but it's just well what if
you didn't
oh god right now it's not a kink for me
it doesn't turn me on no but this one's
kind of like
it's kind of sweet it's sweet but also
kind of sad so they write
she said that she said that her husband
had recently died and they used to do
that
she didn't ask for anything more and my
boyfriend just decided to let her keep
the money
that's like those conscious cuddling
things have you seen that
yeah yeah in japan yeah or like there's
other
i don't know wherever hippie white
people are they do it too i couldn't do
it with another guy like if that was
like a thing that we had and like
he passed like it would just remind me
too much of him and
i think that's what she wants though
like she wants to close her eyes and
pretend her husband is truly
doing it knowing that it's not real he
would smell different so
exactly yeah i read i saw on reddit the
sex worker was like this guy
hired me to come and just sit on his
kitchen
sit in the dining room and he made me
food like a full course meal
and just wanted to eat with me because
he said his wife had just passed away
and he used to always cook for her and
he just wanted to do it again
it was so heartbreaking remember the
girl that i told you about in san
francisco the sex worker
buddy that i have she said like you know
a lot of times they don't want to have
sex like she got paid
thousands to just sit around and watch
game of thrones with
one guy just because they want company
yeah
that's true that's mostly sex work is
companionship yeah the intimate needs
the chill side of it yeah because
there's still a lot of girls [ __ ] a
lot of nasty [ __ ]
so well that's what she said she's like
because she was more like the high end
she's like i got these
who i want to sleep with yeah i'm not
sleeping with gross dudes and i was like
oh you know what
i never thought of that you get to say
no whenever you want to and yes to
whoever and she sent me a picture of one
of the guys i was like
holy [ __ ] like he's actually attracted
gina's friend i know right yeah yeah
dang it's never gonna look like that
right cause you buddy
the comments dude it's so stupid i'm so
curious does she have a pimp or like how
does that work
no she works on her own she's one of
those like high-end escorts how did she
get to be yeah
um without being with an agent can we
interview this chick i've been wanting
to get her to come but then like she
just like
well before quarantine she was busy
developing an app and then she but she
lives all the way up in norcal too and
she's just busy
and now she's on like this spiritual
enlightenment
like she gave me a reading the other day
she's like your your spiritual self is
here i was like wow this is very
interesting
sometimes not there right is it mostly
not there
she's like usually you're dead inside
yeah i think her soul she's here
she said do you see it i'm like no
she's saying it was separate from your
body yeah she's well i mean she's like
imagine it's like imagine like your
higher spirit coming to talk to you what
is she saying
and then for some reason i saw like a
blonde most karen looking person ever
it was a joke am i your spirit animal
probably thank you
thank you like do you think your spirit
self is just as late as you and like
sometimes doesn't show up and sleep
that's why she said oh she's here
she had a stream all night and then she
was sleeping for four days
your soul is just like always a few days
behind you
she shows up like dusting off cheetos
[Laughter]
all right next one i dated a porn star
and did her videography
she had one client who ordered a custom
video
that was just her doing karate moves and
workout clothes
i'll tell you when i first started
shooting slash editing porn never did i
think the toughest part of my job would
be finding different karate sound
effects that blended together while
keeping enough variation for it to be
interesting
why am i messing like shitty chinese
like old man
[Applause]
there's like 37 variations of
god ridiculous i know
but that's kind of funny too like i
wonder what she was doing and like was
she in a
in a very sexual gear like what was it a
very sexy yeah
i picture uma thurman oh true
kill bill yeah interesting there's a
there's a
nerd for everything yeah
all right uh i had a guy with a foot
fetish but he liked
me to stand on his face and not wear
socks the day before so my feet were
stinky if they were dirty
even better he also liked me buying he
also liked to buy me shoes which were
all ugly but hey he paid me to wear them
so i would
oh there was this girl that we knew so
um
my girlfriend she used to date this
really rich guy
and she i remember her telling us like
yeah he doesn't allow me to have
anything else but heels and i'm allowed
one pair of sneakers to work out in
and his fetish was like pointy toed
heels
um so it was always closed toe
and then since he was rich he was always
like excited nice and sweaty in there
yeah it was cool yeah it was almost like
nice jimmy chew heels
and she's like he wasn't allowed or i
wasn't allowed to have any other shoes
on any other time unless i'm working out
and then so when they broke up he
started dating a girl that looked
exactly like her and we started seeing
like
pictures of her and like pointing heels
and it was always like walking on sand
in the beach like even hiking
in like in the dirt hills not hiking but
like in pictures
in the forest with like heels on it was
all these pointy toed heels
and she was your feet are gonna be
[ __ ] up yeah my friend was like my
feet got
[ __ ] up being this guy for years your
toes are permanently like this
like that like a surgery right yeah you
know i hear about women who
who get used to only wearing high heels
like there was this one girl actually
that i met
when in south korea she only could wear
shoes that had a heel on it because if
she wore her if she wore flat
shoes her feet weren't accustomed to
being like flat on the floor so it would
actually
be painful for her oh on the sweet
opposite same same
yeah i don't want heels unless
absolutely necessary these are i can
only do chunky heels now
i can't do like those skinny heels
anymore i can't it hurts my eyes i still
haven't gotten rid of all my shoes from
my 20s just because like i don't in my
head i'm like what if i have to go out
somewhere
i never pick those if i go out they're
like so big
if i had to try i mean maybe i'm just
not as motivated but yeah like when i
was in my
twenties i would definitely power
through i just don't think i could it
definitely makes your legs
look good but yeah it makes me want to
work out yeah
we don't have to try that hard anymore
yeah
i still want to do our thing where we go
clubbing and dressed up as grandmas
i want to yeah that looks so fun so fun
i know i'm so like envious of the girls
from well i guess not
this past year because everything was
closed but in the past like last last
year
how everywhere the the attire for going
out to go to clubs was like boots or
like sneakers
super comfy clothes where it wasn't like
super mini skirts like what we had to
wear back in the day or being freezing
cold body con
dresses yeah when we went out for jess's
birthday which was in 2019 like the very
last that was last time i ever went out
anywhere
but we were at a gay club yeah but i
wore tennis shoes
those dad shoes were in style the dad
all the tennis shoes
yeah the thick those chunky yeah i think
uh one of my and i wear that with a
dress
but one of my most enlightened moments
in my life was when because you guys
know how like i worked in nightlife in
my
20s yeah and like you always have to
show up and look pretty and like heels
and everything
because well one i used to work there so
i had to like be pretty and wear heels
but then i remember one year i went to
vegas with my friends and you know in
vegas all the girls want to dress up and
[ __ ]
i had a moment of enlightenment where
i'm like i don't have to wear heels
i can still wear like a boob tastic
top yeah shorts and like combat boots if
i wanted to yeah
and i'm like oh my god this is
life-changing you guys are [ __ ] dumb
yeah
i still look great yeah
okay next i was a dom and one guy's wife
had
died and he needed someone to just talk
about his grief with and as someone who
lost a partner i could relate if the
club had not let me charge for his
services i for sure wouldn't have
charged him
he used to bring me gifts and from time
to time he wanted me to be
his wife because i look like her oh so
she's
she worked at a strip club and just got
a talker customer
yeah but she was a dumb that's a sad one
that's sad yeah i can't make fun of that
one yeah
that was pretty sad oh more chicken guys
chicken guys all right this next one oh
this one's odd my friend my friend was
friends with a sex worker
one of her clients would buy her cheese
and she would chew it up
and spit it on his naked body while he
masturbate made
that masturbated it was a different
cheese each time i was gonna say what
kind of cheese is that tied in with a
foot fetish because
feet kind of smell like cheat or cheese
kind of felt smells like feet
yeah and it kind of looks like you're
vomiting if you're chewing up cheese and
spitting it out
that one's that was that level was at
least like nice juice or
something like cheese whiz in a can or
like probably that
american singles that's right like
rubbery orange
mozzarella sticks i guarantee you like
that one aged [ __ ]
parmesan all right cheddar ooh blue
cheese blue cheese
or the lemonade hamburger i like what he
ha but that smells like
that's the one that smells like that's
right yeah yeah would be okay i think
for christmas it just reminds me of
throw up the consistency i'm just
chewing up well
chewing up and spitting out anything
yeah i guess but ricotta already is like
what it's like vomit texture it's nice
yeah it's not it's not like that on
everything it's not like it's not always
mushy no
white people love ricotta cheese yes we
do gina they really do i learned from a
white girl
i learned from a white girl it's mild
that's why it's not so stinky
all right well you know what else isn't
stinky
use it right we got a native in the
house
your fetish is delicious smelling
armpits
boy have we got something there are
people who have an armpit fetish yep
we got some fresh scents for them from
native
native cares about the products you put
on your body they're about stopping the
stink
the right way though that's the native
difference you probably already know
about native's legendary
aluminum-free deodorant but have you
tried their body wash
toothpaste or their brand new mineral
based sunscreen i have and it's
fantastic
yes native now has a broad-based spf 30
sunscreen for your face and body there's
two separate ones
it's lightweight absorbs quickly and you
can choose between unscented or coconut
and pineapple if you want to have that
summer smell
everyone i almost called you a [ __ ] but
i won't go there okay native's on a
mission to overhaul your entire hygiene
routine by putting the care in self-care
with products carefully made to work
against odor that are made with simple
ingredients and smell great
you got coconut vanilla you got citrus
and herbal musk you got lavender and
rose
and so much more you can even build your
own personalized product bundles
mix and match three of your favorite
scents keep them on rotation so you have
something for every occasion
look at you go all prepared stay fresh
stay clean with native by going to
nativedio.com
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls at checkout and get 20
off your first order that's
nativedeo.com
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls at checkout for 20 off your
first order
um our next sponsor is billy and you
guys i love this razor i've thrown away
i don't think we're allowed to say
competitor names but i've thrown away my
others
that i used to get and i used to get the
sensitive skin ones because i've always
had like the razor
burn and like just issues don't you get
jealous that's a shitty white skin
okay there's irish skin that no one
wants it's shitty it's just
so i always have to get the sensitive
skin this or that stuff and then
but the billy raiser no no problems at
all
my legs are still very you can't be
showing that for free
my legs yes last night it's very
sharp like the the blades are actually
sharp
close to your other brands have been
selling us
dull razors i feel like and i didn't
realize it until i tried the billy
raiser and it's only nine dollars guys
if you're going to try any of our
sponsors try the billy razor you're not
going to regret it and it has this
little magnet
stick yeah yeah so you like you stick it
to your wall
and then it's there's a magnet like a
shower holder and it's so much prettier
than the suction cup thingy
yeah thinking it's all ugly and great
yeah
so this one's cute um yeah go to
mybilly.com to meet the razor that made
everyone start talking
about razors i believe it the spicer
actually to me feels different
um to express a little love for our show
go to mybilly.com
mood it's a small way you can support us
while getting the best razor you will
ever own
it's just nine dollars to get your
starter kit plus free shipping always
go to mybilly.com mood spelled
my and then b i l l i e dot com
slash mood oh yeah and i don't laser so
like that area
the down there area it's like i didn't
get any
ingrown hairs or any bumps or anything
it's a really smooth shade
yeah it's a really good razor alrighty
what else do we have on deck with these
weirdos
okay stop shaming jessica i am a 100
percent king shangri
come after me give me your kink i'll
shame it yeah
i don't have any that's why i'm a shamer
all right well you're the vanilla sex
girl
yeah no jess is gonna love this one the
vanilla one oh it's this is jess's
favorite okay everyone it's jose's
favorite i love it
i'm ready a client wanted me to send
them foot shavings
[Laughter]
shaving things like head shape it says
like ped
egg ped egg parmesan foot shavings
i figured i'm not using them why not oh
like when you
like yeah there's like the you know the
color yeah because i have the headache
but i never
i never use it i like the promise better
but that stuff like it literally just
leaves shavings inside of the air
you should go work the guy that has this
fetish should go work at a
go do pictures because they they pull
out a drill
and they were drilling away at your feet
i would be terrible my feet are
soft as [ __ ] i wouldn't be able to
provide anything oh wow yeah
what a problem princess feet i got a
little i got a little that i could get
rid of but not a lot
again i would just sell steve's yeah
[Laughter]
it'd probably smell nice and rain too
yeah you'd probably get a return
this should be a side hustle for like
all the nail salons
yeah dude yeah i mean you know
like companies should make use of even
as much of their waste
there's like a foot condition where like
their their heel or foot or whatever
develops very thick thick where yeah
extremely
to like have you guys people seen like
people like shaving soap bars yeah so
imagine that like it's like the curls
yes oh like a lot like whoever has that
foot would make a killing in this
guy it's like medical right yeah
medicine or something cause
you're thinking of that for someone
they're they probably
in their ancestors walked barefoot
across mountains
oh yeah something like that developed
their genes they genetically evolved to
like
yeah damn all right next one i was a cam
girl and i've gotten
tons of story oh and i've got tons of
stories one of the weirdest
was a short skit that was very specific
and clearly half a scenario for example
me nodding at specific timestamps
pointing to my left boob smiling at
specific time stamps
then saying goodbye in a really cryptic
way i asked he was the buyer
[ __ ] so he could he could yeah so he
could narrate his own voice like do you
like that and she's like
oh yeah how much do you like he has a he
has a [ __ ] vanna white
uh fetish for what is it uh pointing
yeah like
wheel of fortune fortune she's like
pointing it oh yeah
by a vowel i can't even imagine what
that footage turned out i know right
and then she says i asked the buyer what
it was for and it turns out it was to
act out a scene from an anime i got five
hundred dollars so i'm not complaining
oh god i wanna know which enemy's so bad
yeah yeah
it was so bad yeah which one did they
point to their boob to the left
that's like all animes
i'm sorry excuse my ignorance i'm sorry
there's this one guy that emailed me
back when i was like i think it was like
in my early 20s he's like i want to pay
to um have you
blindfolded and i tickle your feet and
you just laugh but it's not sexual i'm
like okay
[Music]
okay i could probably look it up right
now let me see if it's still like
i don't know i'm sorry guys are just
dumb they're so dumb
blind like no for sure it's not sexual
it's kind of guys because i swear it's
not it's not i'm not weird
you're right i know i gotta like it's
gotta be something that's pretty ballsy
though that they're ashamed enough to
say it's not
maybe it's not but let's say it is but
they're not ashamed enough to just not
even
go through with even asking it's like
damage controlling the possible response
right yeah how could that not be sexual
like you just want to tickle like
guys only want to tickle a girl and then
they get boners like come on every
boyfriend i've had that tickled me
immediately got a bone
really yes oh wait what you've never
gotten tickled by your boyfriend or your
husband
yeah but they immediately get with a
boner yeah
every single guy in my entire life maybe
i attract that kind of guy
but every guy that's enjoyed for
whatever reason tickling me
it's wound up with a boner dude i'm
actually and i'm like jesus here we go
you give good tickle laughs oh god
how could you knock it through maybe
it's because i'm such a [ __ ] normally
that when they see me laughing they're
like oh my god
i made her happy made her happy yeah
let's get it going oh my god
funny but i shouldn't be judging because
i realized i'm the tickler
that gets turned on i don't get turned
on
you take it back i don't get turned on
it's when i'm turned on
my way of telling my husband that i'm
turned on is by tickling him and i don't
know why
it doesn't turn me on but you're already
turned on you know i'm already turned on
but that's my way of trying to initiate
sex i don't know how to
approach him other than going yeah it's
weird
that's really what i used to do in high
school it's a weird thing that i've
developed
i wasn't like that before that couple
sits in the corner like stop
and this is this was this hasn't been a
forever thing like it just started a few
years ago interesting
i don't know why so then and then casey
hates getting tickled so he's
he actually got mad once where he was
like you need to stop tickling me i'm
like i'm sorry it's just
i don't know how to tell you that i i
want sex like this is just what's
happening
i don't want to work on like literally
anything else with titty and he'll get
the hell yeah
you literally just say hey i want you
just just plop out the dogs
like leave a man alone it's so stupid
and weird i don't know it's [ __ ]
weird i don't know what happened to my
brain but yeah i don't know why it's
just
hard for me to just be like i could just
touch his dick and make it happen
but i got an eight-year-old boy
it is it's like i'm embarrassed or
something i don't know why
i don't know like i said it's a new
thing that's what we need therapy so
let's go yeah
okay next one i once had both of my
fists up
someone's butt all right i got pissed
okay
that's not sexual i was not sexual
that's not all right it's not
but when you say a fist that means the
hands are yes
right like this oh like that because if
you have like this
that's it that's a shake a shame shake
it with both hands
oh a shaker it's a handshake oh yeah
a calling a prayer that's a prayer oh my
god i was praying i was praying inside
this
okay they continue i got paid and it was
fantastic i felt like i was conducting a
science experiment also my client was
quite attractive
in there [ __ ] you're feeling she was
pulling at her hands in someone's
[ __ ] where there's probably
she could have been a dude too could
have been a guy
up there i feel like it is kind of a
science experiment what what finger is
like ew
fists i'm like my wrists aren't i just
thought of something
like this he's like yeah
this just reminded me of a tick tock
that i saw
and have you guys ever i don't know if
this is real i gotta google this but
have you guys heard of
fisting tattoos what what yeah no um
okay so apparently have you guys ever
seen those tattoos of people just have
like a line that goes around oh
my google search just just i know people
just like
getting stripes around their arm for
something up here does that mean
i mean that would kill someone like i
don't believe that people are sticking
that [ __ ]
that far up there this like this much up
your butt
so the first is doesn't your butt have
to like curve like right
i mean there's like a mile of navigating
curved like you can't just go
straight up someone's ass okay so i
googled fisting tattoo okay
and then it says why do people get their
fisting records tattooed
it's a line on their arm and it and it's
like you can't i've seen it
and everyone thinks you fisted someone i
know i've seen that on way too many
people
that's gotta be like some 4chan [ __ ]
like trolling
people actually just saw a picture of a
dude getting fisted okay oh okay what
does that look like
don't send it over here armband okay
that's another oh you want to see the
fishing with it i've never seen that i
don't know i'm curious
oh nothing more than a penis should go
in an [ __ ] i don't want to okay
okay people happen okay fisting tattoos
just got traumatized yeah exactly right
well i asked for it it's like it's like
when they inseminate cows
like that yeah traumatic enough for me
to see i'm like oh
yeah yeah okay so he had gloves on for
that yeah
well some people might just look just
like the look of the armband tattoos
others get them to let the world know
they enjoy anal fisting
or they also have these measurement
things here it's like a ruler on your
arm a ruler tattooed on your forearm
yeah
and then see there's those black bands
this is the line that goes all the way
around the other
trend i thought you're just trying too
hard at that point right like if i
ever let everyone know like if i meet
someone wearing a tank top and their
band is all the way up here
i'm i'm gonna be very that's the tattoo
equivalent of like smell my finger yeah
gross i fingered so you know in high
school now i feel bad for people who
have that tattoo
but for not fisting reasons and they're
just like oh [ __ ]
so they're like a fisting dom and they
gotta show everyone how far they can get
it up
and like when you're in there do you get
a marker to markets and the next time
if i was like that i would just lie
look how much i can do yeah look how
cool i am like if i had to show the
world how cool i am
wait you're saying that's how much they
they can take so they measure their own
and tattoo it which they suck up someone
else's
i think yeah how much they want stuff
yeah
yeah interesting all right so now i'm
curious about those because now i i
realize i know a couple people
that have those are just trendy i think
those are just trying i hope so because
i do not want to see this
image inside because i can pray for them
to be treated
way too many oh the lines line up here
both of them all right next one
um i always had someone i had someone
always pay good money to touch my legs
and lick my armpits
he paid really well why did he want to
lick my armpit i don't know
there's actually pheromones in your
armpits so that makes sense
can you imagine looking deodorant off of
it i would never
um all right next one i once had a lady
pay me to be her date at her sister's
wedding and have sex with her during the
reception in a bathroom
oh that's kind of cool what yeah i could
see that happening
a lady paid him okay let's say like
you're single you're sick of being
single you hate weddings jess
you could probably relate like seeing
people that are in love so opposite from
what you're feeling
so you just want to like if you're going
to get to this wedding at least you
could go [ __ ] in the bathroom have a
little adventure
yeah i could see it free cake
free it just freezing like your inner
like you're interjecting your [ __ ] on
someone else's day
yeah i don't know it just feels totally
it is it is responsible for sure
disrespectful
but i can see the mindset of somebody
who
is maybe bitter if they're like not
really your friend i guess yeah that's
your sister
yeah it was her sister's wedding oh [ __ ]
and then there could be some siblings
yeah i guess so if i kind of like didn't
really like
whose wedding i was going to i guess but
like she has to be there because her
sister
yeah that's really interesting at least
you get to bang someone
back and then probably this lady too she
might have had like
family issues to the point where it's
like they keep bugging her when are you
gonna get married or when are you gonna
have kids or maybe she just got out of a
failing relationship and then now she's
just like
[ __ ] y'all i'm gonna have sex in the
bathroom yeah i don't know
anyway this is the last one here it says
this one was the sweetest one
a guy paid me to send poetry and
playlist he paid he made for me
oh wait wait he sent money and poetry
yes and playlist what a self so
he paid to send her his work yeah
oh okay but like that he made for her oh
so she was like a romantic gesture kind
of thing i think he just wanted a
girlfriend
i don't know why he would send money
that's weird he could just send the
poems and [ __ ]
yeah yeah maybe because she had to maybe
part of the money was like
she had to love it and she had to be
grateful for it i don't know she kind of
like
to be like i like the part when you
talked about the leaves falling
you know like you kind of like give
feedback or something i'm watching my
hair i love when you rhyme dog with log
it's so romantic how is that romantic i
don't know my eyes are like a sunset
yeah it's all shitty poetry
that's funny i did have a phase as a as
a teenage
like crazy ass hormonal teenage
phase where i was writing poetry yeah
yeah occasionally in my journal it'll
come up but have you ever had a guy
like write you poetry i don't think i've
ever had a guy write me
poetry or i guess a playlist one of my
boyfriends looked into playlists but
oh yeah i've done playlists yeah i've
never had a guy write me poetry
i think i would probably [ __ ] on it if
they did so oh that's so [ __ ] up chess
you're so
mean if it's gonna be a poem it'd be
like where are all these guys [ __ ] it
better me poetry
talking about how talking about how
beautiful i am
and then shitty poetry and then the
other episodes like how sweet i want a
sweet guy
yeah what's going on that's sweet i was
never into poetry
i just want a guy that's not gonna lie
and cheat on all that type of [ __ ] not
that bad to me it sounds
kind of sweet it is not my kind of
romance
sure it depends on how they present it
too if they're doing it to be
like the like praised then i picture
yeah yeah
picture poets as people who want they
want this
the whatever self yeah
it's about them more than it is about me
that's what that's what i wanted
that's what i made up in my mind about
someone yeah i don't like that poem but
if they were just write a little shitty
poem and put in my lunchbox yeah
if it was
i think if it was like funny or witty i
would enjoy it but if it was like super
serious i would be like
what if it's in a text not that serious
like a lot like how well like a short
like it's like a hike
yeah like like it depends on because
you're hard if he's writing my love
right you know if it's a shitty funny
one great but if he's writing like
robert frost in my text message yeah can
you [ __ ] kill
what if he was a poet like he is a yeah
like okay
like one of our friends we like i won't
maybe say their name but i love them um
they have like a poetry thing like and
they do
slam poetry poetry no no i know who it
is yeah well
i think if they're good at it yeah
and they just happened to write part of
their yeah
i know who you're talking about and i
feel like one from him wouldn't be so
exactly but it just most people i
picture who you picture acoustic guitar
guy who brings his guitar to the party
that's like yeah yeah
it's so cringy to me i love slamming it
it depends on how i like it it's pulled
off
yeah like you have to have the right
kind of swag to pull it off
otherwise you just like come off off
like it's difficult to be good at it
kind of like stand up anyway it's
difficult to be good to stand up i think
if i ever
try to do it it would come off as a joke
because it's just like
so out there for me but i love watching
it
i i think that i think the one the ones
that i hate are the stereotypical ones
yeah the song was five and there was a
band
yeah and then you know like i hate that
you know but
why do you hate it i just think it's so
it's part of the performance like
like when you get off the stage i'm
going to bully you in the back alley you
know like you were just
like bullying poets this group was out
there
they have like bahrain associated with
people
yeah i [ __ ] hate those you hate
snapping i hate that [ __ ]
i hate it just and then but then like i
i do there is one boat that i love that
he does read on stage but he reads it
normally and it's cool
but if it's like the the 90s
stereotypical
yeah no yeah i like i don't know there
was this one channel
like i think called button poetry or
something like that but it got me into
i went on a binge of like watching all
of these slam po and i really liked it
it was more of like a
a monologue performance piece than
like the the 90s type of like beatnik
type
things like i think it's just so like um
uh what is it like you know those people
go to museums like
yes it speaks to me it's a [ __ ]
period blood dot on the wall
too many turtlenecks on too many it's
the pretentiousness of it
yeah yeah it's like my body is milk and
he's lactose intolerant
yeah i'm bullying you
yeah well anyway thank you guys so much
for listening hope you enjoy these if
you have any crazy
sex stories leave them in the comments
and we're always down to
read them some of us will judge them
not all of us but i mean one a fourth of
us
will judge them a quarter of this is
very
judgmental and if you do slam poetry
i meant every
do word that's why you love us right
that's why you guys keep coming back
because you we have such a diverse
group here and that's why we love you
too because
you support us and you support us by
hitting up our sponsors yeah yeah
it's actually my personal kink for you
to hit up yeah sponsors
i won't kink shame buying from our
sponsors yeah yeah
every time you use our code nikki feels
like
no i don't know jess that's more
satisfying yeah cause it's like
you need to win her approval yeah yeah
like tickling her
all right guys well thank you so much
for watching we love you see you next
time bye